rattraper le retard au plus vite moscow
essayer de booster radicalement les
chiffres des personnes vaccinées avec
une population de 15 millions
d'habitants la capitale compte seulement
trois millions de personnes ayant reçu
au moins une dose du rom aide
avec ce nouveau centre de vaccination le
processus devrait aller plus vite
la reine sportif de loge nikki qui a vu
la finale du mondial du football de 2018
s'est transformé en plus grands vox
hinault de rome du monde
à en croire le maire de moscou sergueï
sobianine et s'ils travaillent vingt
cinq médecins 99 infirmières et pour
assurer que tout se passe dans les
meilleurs délais le personnel médical
est assisté par 99 agents des centres de
services administratifs et 125 agents
des services sociaux le centre de
vaccination accueille surtout des
travailleurs étrangers ayant résidence
en russie aujourd'hui depuis 8h30 nous
recevons des citoyens étrangers
nous n'avons pratiquement aucun retard
les citoyens étrangers sont vaccinés en
l'espace de 6 à 10 minutes
le vaccin spoutnik light qui leur est
administré un vaccin seuls composants
élaboré en russie
le médecin procède à l'examen vérifie la
température et étudie le formulaire de
demande avant de délivrer un certificat
préremplie et de diriger l'intéressé
vers l'infirmière pour vaccination selon
sergueï sobianine les situations
épidémiologiques à moscou commence à se
stabiliser au point que les autorités
ont décidé de ne pas introduire pour
l'instant de nouvelles restrictions et
même de rouvrir certains espaces urbains
en plein air ces derniers jours la
situation concernant la propagation du
coronavirus se stabilise progressivement
le taux de cas détectés et
d'hospitalisation demeure très élevé
mais au moins il a un peu diminué par
rapport au pic de la semaine dernière la
stabilisation de la propagation du virus
inspire un optimisme prudent
cependant le danger toujours présents
les risques de contracter le virus est
de tomber gravement malade sont très
élevés la lutte contre le coc vide 19
n'est possible
par la vaccination de masse maintenant
chaque jour environ 100000 personnes
reçoivent une injection d'un des 80 100
russe disponible à moscou avec plus de
6000 nouveaux cas de corona virus
détecté dans la capitale ces dernières
vingt quatre heures la ville pourrait
finalement devancé la souche delta dans
la course contre l'amour